à des kilomètres des stades et des
visiteurs internationaux il se
réunissent pour vivre leur mondiale
celui qu'ils ont bâti
sourire et photos croquée sur le vif les
travailleurs migrants qui profitent
d'une rare soirée de congés regarde les
parties gratuitement dans un stade de
cricket en rêvant dit assister en
personne
dans ce stade de 13000 places on ne vend
pas de bière à 20 dollars la nourriture
qui est en vente et népalaise indienne
pakistanaise et la Coupe du monde
construit plus que tout et celle de
cricket pas celle de football ici c'est
l'autre visage cette Coupe du Monde
l'autre visage de Doha
la plupart de ces travailleurs migrants
vivent seuls à Doha attirer au Qatar par
les promesses de travail pour aider
leurs familles dans leur pays d'origine
de fausses assurances selon ce
sénégalais il affirme que plusieurs
entreprises ne l'ont jamais payé pas
bien on ne peut pas bien tu sais tu ça
va être dur on te payer pas bien avec le
Time trop long
c'est pas facile
depuis l'an dernier un salaire minimum
de l'équivalent de 375 dollars canadien
par mois a été instauré au Qatar
certains juge malgré tout les conditions
de travail des sortes
sont ceux qui ne font pas attention à
leur santé affirme ce n'est pas l'être
bon nombre de ces travailleurs migrants
ne sont au Qatar que pour la Coupe du
monde ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils feront
ensuite
Dieu est bon les occasions de travail
viendront la majorité encourage le Qatar
mais il se régale aussi début de leurs
adversaires le foot est une évasion
temporaire le temps d'une soirée ici
Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada